We'll be speaking with Dr and [inaudible]
professor of psychology at the
University of California Berkeley and a
member of the Institute for Personality
and Social Research on
schizophrenia and emotion.
Dr. King received a BS in psychology from
Ball State University and her MBA and
phd in clinical psychology from the State
University of New York at Stony Brook.
Dr [inaudible] research focuses on emotion
and psych pathology with a specific
interest in the emotional
features of schizophrenia,
assessing negative symptoms
of schizophrenia and the
linkage between cognition
and emotion and schizophrenia.
In addition,
she also studies emotion healthy
individuals with a focus on individual
differences and expressive behavior,
gender differences in emotion and
linkages between cognition, personality,
social context and emotion.
Dr. Craig has received numerous awards
including a young investigator award from
the national lines for research
on schizophrenia and depression,
the Joseph Subin Memorial Fund Award and
the Distinguished Teaching Award from
UC Berkeley.
She's currently president elect for the
Society for research and psychopathology
and has served as an associate editor
for the Journal of abnormal psychology as
well as cognition and emotion and a
member of the editorial boards for
Schizophrenia Bulletin.
Psychological Science and the public
interest and applied and preventative
psychology, emotion and Journal
of research in personality.
She's also the author or editor of three
books and several scholarly papers in
top journals in the field.
So I now turn to our special experts in
emotion interview with doctor and crane
on schizophrenia and emotion.
Com.
And thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me.
So I wanted to ask you as a place to
start sort of what your journey into the
world of emotion was. So what first got
you interested in the topic of emotion?
Well,
when I was a graduate student I was
looking around for some sort of research,
uh, to land on and uh, it
wasn't schizophrenia, but, uh,
I had an advisor that was interested in
schizophrenia and interested in some of
the symptoms of schizophrenia, which to
me sounded an awful lot like a problem,
that emotion. So that led me, um,
as a graduate student 20 years ago to
really start reading about basic emotion
research.
And that's when I first got the idea to
translate some of the research and basic
emotion to the study of schizophrenia.
Yeah.
So speaking of that,
I'd love to now ask you some questions
about your research on emotions,
schizophrenia. And so, I mean,
you've really pioneered this field and
really advanced almost everything we know
about the realm of
emotion and schizophrenia.
And one of the things that has been
most interesting and sort of most
illuminating was really,
um,
understanding the way in which
emotion experience on the one hand,
maybe intact and schizophrenia,
whereas other domains, you know,
like expressive behavior
may be less intact.
So you've described this
as the disjunction between
different components of
emotional responding.
And I was wondering if you could say a
little bit more about how research has
illuminated this potential disconnect
between internal emotion experience on the
one hand and external emotion
behavior on the other,
among individuals with schizophrenia.
Well,
again,
it started as a graduate to really
where I was reading all this fascinating
research in basic emotion in healthy
people. And so I thought, well,
why not use those same methods,
uh,
to understand what's happening in
schizophrenia. Prior to doing that,
I think people in the field of
schizophrenia thought that, um,
people without people with schizophrenia
just had no emotion at all.
They were just completely without emotion.
And so what we did was we actually
imported some laboratory paradigms to the
study of schizophrenia and we took a
close look at their outward expression,
their experience, their physiology.
And what we found was quite surprising.
I think too many people who had
studied schizophrenia for years,
and that will cause that just as you said,
that people with schizophrenia reported
feeling things very, very strongly,
just as strongly as healthy
people did. They, uh, they, uh,
felt very happy and amused.
Um,
they felt very disgusted
and scared and sad.
But what distinguished people with
schizophrenia from people without
schizophrenia was almost a complete
lack of outward expression.
So we would show people
I'm using film clips or uh,
put a plate of tasty food in front of
them or a show them some very disturbing
pictures or ask them to tell
sad stories about their lives.
And no matter what we would do,
people with schizophrenia would
say they felt things very strongly.
They felt very amused. They felt
very pleasant. They felt very sad,
but yet they would not show that
on their face. They didn't cry,
they didn't show a lot of smiles. Um,
so this is the disconnect it with that.
We observed that people with
schizophrenia field things strongly,
they just don't show it outwardly.
And so they kind of simple
a take home message from,
from this line of work is that you, you
don't want to judge a book by its cover.
Just because someone would get to phrenia
it doesn't show an outward expression
of emotion.
Doesn't mean that they don't feel it
because chances are they feel things very
strong.
And so how did this work at the time fit
with previous conceptualizations of the
emotional lives of individuals
with schizophrenia?
Well as I said that, uh, before
that I think that the typical, uh,
view of people with schizophrenia was
that their lives were emotional vacuums.
They just had no feelings.
They,
they didn't show any feelings
that a what a bleak existence.
So I'm so I think people mistakenly
assumed that because people with
schizophrenia and weren't
expressing emotion,
they weren't laughing at funny joke.
So they weren't looking scared or when a
car came barreling down the street that
they just had no emotion experience.
But that was absolutely not the case.
They just weren't showing it outwardly,
but they were feeling it very strongly.
Okay.
So you've also demonstrated another really
interesting feature of the emotional
experience in lives of people with,
which is that they show these really
unique patterns of emotional related
difficulties that depend on sort of the
timing or temporal frame of the emotion
itself.
And I wondered if you could say a bit
more about your work that's really teased
apart this distinction
between the anticipation of
emotion versus the more kind
of online consumer Tory experience of
emotion among people with schizophrenia.
Well that that blind of researcher rose
from an interesting paradox we observed.
So I'm, one of the symptoms of
schizophrenia is called Anhedonia,
which means,
uh,
a lack of interest or pleasure
in things in life. Um,
it's not specific to schizophrenia.
People with depression also have this,
but it's a pretty common symptom.
As many as three quarters of people with
schizophrenia have this symptom, uh,
which would suggest that in the
presence of something pleasurable,
I'm a milkshake or a amusing
heartwarming film clip.
People with schizophrenia shouldn't
enjoy it, but in fact they do.
And that's what we demonstrated in our
early studies that in the presence of
pleasant things, people with schizophrenia
enjoy it just the same as as you are.
I would. So how then could they
have the symptom of an Idonia?
So that led us to think about,
uh,
what is the time course of an
emotional response. And so certainly,
uh, when you present somebody with
something or you have a tasty meal,
you enjoy that, that we call that in
the moment or consumer Tory pleasure.
But there are other aspects of the
timing of an emotional response. So,
for example,
just even thinking about what am I
going to have for lunch today that might
conjure up a representation or an image
of what you might like to have for lunch
and then, um, that would then
make you anticipate that, boy,
I'm really looking forward to having a,
uh,
a tasty salad for lunch.
And so you might even have a kind of a
mental image of that salad and you might
really be looking forward to it and you
might feel good now knowing that you're
going to have a,
a tasty salad for lunch and
that anticipatory pleasure
we call that will then
motivate you to get up and leave and
go get a that the tasty salad for lunch
show up. Um, uh, and then
you have it and you enjoy it.
So what we then begin to think about
the problem that schizophrenia is not so
much enjoying,
they're tasty salad,
but it comes in the looking forward to
it or the anticipatory pleasure of that.
And so we did a number of laboratory
studies and we also did a study called an
experience sampling study
where we took a look at, uh,
the emotions that people
with schizophrenia experience
in their daily lives in
the context of the things that they do.
And what we found was in fact that people
with schizophrenia do have trouble in
anticipating that things in the future,
whether it's a tasty salad for lunch
or going out to a movie with friends or
visiting with family,
they have trouble anticipating or
predicting that that will be pleasurable.
And that in turn interferes
with their motivation,
their behavior to go seek
out those pleasurable things.
But once they have those pleasurable
things, whether they're having, um,
a tasty lunch or watching a movie
with friends, visiting with family,
they'll enjoy it.
But where they're going to have difficulty
is anticipating that they will enjoy
it and then seeking it out or going
after those kinds of activities in life.
I mean,
it's just so interesting.
It reveals how complex the nature
of emotion isn't schizophrenia.
And so based on these really interesting
and nuanced insights that we now have
in the schizophrenia, thanks to your
work, um, you know, it makes me wonder,
you know,
to what extent can we be translating these
to interventions for individuals with
schizophrenia,
which I know is something you're
actively doing in your own work now.
Well,
we,
we have to in these findings and tried
to translate them both into assessments
and into a interventions for
people with schizophrenia. So, um,
the most standard way of assessing,
um,
some of the problems that
people with schizophrenia,
my experience as a clinical interview.
And so, uh, along with my colleagues,
we've developed a new, uh, interview, uh,
for the symptoms of schizophrenia
that specifically targets anticipatory
pleasure. Um, so that we're
actually building that into
our assessments now. Um,
but we're also trying to work to
develop some psychosocial treatments for
schizophrenia because unfortunately,
uh,
the best we have to offer people with
schizophrenia right now anyway in terms of
treatment is medication and the
medications don't really do a good job of
helping with this anticipatory pleasure,
a deficit or this problem and
outward expression of emotion.
So we've developed a couple
of psychosocial treatments.
One involves a type of meditation
that focuses on emotion.
Another is a skills based treatment that
really tries to build people's skills
and uh,
looking forward to things in the future
and savoring and hanging on to those
emotional experiences,
um,
as an effort to try to make a
dent in some of these problems.
And anticipatory pleasure.
I mean, when you've also, I mean,
another line of work related to all
this is identifying important sources of
gender variation and emotion among
individuals with schizophrenia.
And I wondered if you could just tell
us a bit more about that too. Well,
in some of the early studies we did
where we identified that people with
schizophrenia work showing very
many outward expressions of emotion,
almost all those studies were done with
men. So it left this big gaping question.
Is that also the case for
women with schizophrenia?
Because we know in healthy
people that in general,
men tend to be less expressive than women.
Women are more readily show all
sorts of outward expressions.
And so we wondered if our
observations of this, um,
diminish outward expression and emotion
might be just a function of our having
studied only men. So we didn't
have worked to recruit, uh,
samples of women with schizophrenia.
And here what we find actually is the
same thing that women with schizophrenia
are also very much diminished in their
outward expression of emotion compared to
women without schizophrenia. So, uh,
even though women in general tend
to be more expressive than men,
women was schizophrenia also tend not
to show very many outward expressions of
emotion,
but also like Ben was schizophrenia,
women with schizophrenia feel things
very strongly, just the same as men.
Was schizophrenia just the same as
healthy men and women. Um, so, uh,
what we've been able to see that despite
the fact that women in general are more
expressive than men,
that doesn't seem to be the case
with people with schizophrenia.
Women who have schizophrenia are
also not very outwardly expressive.
Hmm.
So it seems that some of the common
gender differences among men and women and
turns of expressivity are slightly
altered an impacted when a diagnosis of
schizophrenia is at play.
[inaudible] right. Great.
So this is really interesting to hear
about kind of what got you into emotion in
the first place in all the discoveries
you've done illuminating the nature of
emotion and schizophrenia,
how it's relevant for you know,
intervention and treatment and what are
some important sources of sort of gender
variation, you know, in,
in this emotional profile.
And so I wonder as you think about
sort of where you've come from and what
you've done, sort of where
things are going, um,
in terms of where do you see the future
of emotion research headed from here?
The big question, sorry.
I think, uh, you know,
it's a good question though.
I think this is a super exciting
time for emotion research because,
um, I think, you know, for the
first time in probably 30 years,
there's some really exciting
new theoretical models of
emotion that are turning
our,
uh,
kind of longstanding conceptualizations
about what emotion is on his head.
And those are exciting.
I think paradigm shifting moments
in the field of emotion. So, um,
if the past 20 years of,
um,
newer imaging research
has taught us anything,
I think it's taught us that the brain
doesn't really recognize our discrete
categories of emotion that
we use and lay life. Uh,
but also that's really been at the
forefront of emotion of research. Um,
the idea that emotion,
the emotion pie can be carved up into
things like happiness and anger and fear.
You know, the brain just doesn't
respond that way really, um,
to these different discrete categories
and make common sense to us and that have
guided our research. What we
know now is really that, uh,
emotion,
and this is a,
I think one of the most exciting
theories is that some of the work of Lisa
Feldman Barrett showing us that emotion
is a very similar to other sorts of
psychological processes that we
experienced in daily life. But yet, uh,
what we've learned about emotion to
our language and just the simple act of
labeling can really influence how we feel.
The label a term like
happiness can really constrain,
um, the way we perceive emotion in other
people, the way that we ourselves feel.
Um,
and that is something that we've
learned and constructed an imposed upon,
uh, the feelings that we have in
our bodies and make sense of a,
as we navigate through the world.
So I think probably in the
next 10 years or more, um,
uh,
people are gonna look back on our kind
of antiquated views of emotion and we'll
have a whole new paradigm I
think for thinking about emotion,
which is exciting I think for the field.
And I think one of the things
that's exciting for the
field to is thinking about
what the next generation of scholars
and students are going to look like.
And you know, as someone who
learned emotion from you, um,
you're my very first mentor, you know,
into this field. That was emotion.
My favorite question to ask you is sort
of what advice do you have for students
embarking on emotion?
I know you've given me a lot of great
advice that I now give to my own students.
Um, and so I'd love to hear just the
advice that you could share with a broader
audience of what,
what should students be focusing on or
what are the most interesting puzzles
they should try to approach?
Well,
if people are interested in emotion,
I don't know if this is the advice
that I gave you, but it would be,
I would say to study broadly and not just
stay within the fields of emotion but
read in philosophy and in a
neuroscience and in economics of cause.
We emotion is something that impacts
a daily life across all fields and,
and walks of life.
Um,
so to get kind of a broad
conceptualization of emotion,
get outside of a psychology
and read broadly and study, uh,
just to emotion as it unfolds in
a daily life. I think that, um,
we'll give people,
um,
who are interested in becoming scholars
of emotion and a really nice perspective
rather than a very,
a narrow one that we all can sometimes
get when we just stay within our,
uh,
individual fields boundaries.
Well, thank you so much and
for speaking with us today.
You're welcome.
Thanks for having me.
Well, it's a pleasure always. Um,
so this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with doctor and cream from
the University of California Berkeley.
Thanks again Ann.